the biggest names in fashion serve as a
research material for one of Britain's
best selling authors of all time sophie
kinsella guru of the chiclet genre malls
are an inspiration for her books which
address issues of modern womanhood in a
humorous and light-hearted way Kinsella
shopaholic series out since 2000 has
made her famous the books follow The
Adventures of Becky Bloomwood and her
series had funny addiction to shopping
so is the character
semi-autobiographical there is a lot of
Becky bloom with that is just me on the
page some of it is what her situation is
at the beginning she's a financial
journalist lusting after shoes and I was
a financial journalist lusting after
shoes so that was me and a lot of the
way she thinks is me so when she thinks
well you know what I bought that on sale
so that was like saving money that's
completely me you know what when I can't
think of what to write next I go to the
mall I mean what's not to love it's
bright and shiny and warm and inviting
there's a kind of bars there are people
and it's just a very inspirational
placement forty-six-year-old Kinsella
study music and philosophy at Oxford
before becoming a journalist and later a
writer when starting a new book she says
planning and knowing an ending are
crucial
well every book starts with a tiny idea
and I let that ideas sit with me and
then I start to plan it out I go to
coffee shops great inspiration I sit I
plan and I think courageous and then
when I really know the story I know the
characters and all the issues then I
start writing properly fans got a taste
of the latest book in the series
shopaholic to the rescue at a reading in
Berlin it's just been published in
German with an English title it details
Becky's chaotic trip to Las Vegas in
search of her father but I've always
been nervy around policemen ever since i
smuggled six pairs of Dali's shoes out
of hamleys aged 5 and a policeman came
up to me and boomed what have you got
there young lady her books have been
translated into 41 languages and if I
don't happy up a friend of mine bought
me the book pickle my name is also
Rebecca serve I had to read it and it
made me laugh it's be sublime [ __ ]
faded I like the way she writes it's
very funny and fresh something different
compared to the other romance books out
there hers aren't so cheesy that's why
I'm hooked I'm my infancy item near
buzzy is she writes from the heart and
describes characters were really joyful
you can identify with them if it's young
gun Kinsella has written over 20 books
selling more than 36 million copies
globally but does this one the eighth in
the series spelled the end for Becky
Bloomwood oh don't say she's gonna
retire in my head she'll go on forever
my trouble is time I have so many
stories I want to tell and I've been
working on a great new standalone novel
but i do have ideas for becky and i'm
really excited about what she has in
store sophie kinsella also writes under
her real name Madeleine Wickham besides
being a best-selling author she's a wife
and mother of five for her time is of
the essence but she still allows herself
the luxury of conducting proper research
for her books including the occasional
purchase or two
for sophie kinsella there's only a fine
line between the worlds of reality and
fiction